the spectrum definitely had a major
impact on on Britain which was then
boosted by the BBC machines and there's
the endorsement by the BBC as a
corporation with their TV programs well
what happens now we have to load the
programming into the machine so your
type load el away the arm to learn about
computers note that in a fighh one the
amazing BBC micro I mean it was an
incredible machine the government hopes
to have a computer in every secondary
school by the end of the year and last
month the further 9 million pounds was
allocated to extend the scheme to the
primary schools and judging by the
pupils response computers are in school
for good how would you describe the
children's reaction to computers well
and the main they're very very
enthusiastic about computers as you seen
for yourselves took the computer club is
usually swamped by the very young
children our school and you got BBC
micros just after I left which is really
annoying but having said that they got
them and they were really popular
because one of the beauties of the BBC
micro is you could deploy a piece of
software to every machine and clustering
with single command that is really
really powerful no descriptor them very
very simple and that was actually a
great machine for tinkering with for
pulling apart and see how things work
and we were so enthusiastic about
programming computers and stuff we just
had to get our hands on a BBC model B it
seemed like the best run and I quite
fancied having a good one rather than
starting a bit lower down and a cheaper
level hold
have something I could do something with
everything about it just seemed to be to
make it better so I was quite easy to
start creating programs of that but also
had built in graphics which meant you
could very easily produce images and
then move them around and then I started
moving things on the screen really
quickly and that in itself it was quite
an addictive process when you have
success use words you're on so I was
quite happy then to get stuck in and try
and produce something a bit more
challenging BBC be was a very nice very
nice elegant platform and the way they
designed it was a straightforward very
logical has a very kind of almost
philosophical 10 years to it very well
thought out quite people that obviously
love programming and into to support
programming and that's kind of what BBC
be was about is about you've made by
programs plus it had the best games
Oh
you